puis perle un économiste bonsoir
philippe herlin merci d'être avec nous
alors la bce 1 qui perd net sonnette
d'alarmé ce que vous partagez son
inquiétude
inquiétude oui la quiétude alliés réel
parce que tous les pays d'europe vont
subir une récession extrêmement forte
voilà maintenant je suis pas certain que
ce soit la bonne solution
tout tout tout tout les munitions qui
sont utilisés en ce moment ce sont des
ddd logique keynésienne c'est-à-dire de
dépenses publiques dont il ya les états
à leur niveau qui dépensent 2 qui
dépense énormément d'argent qui font
exploser leur budget et puis on voit en
rajouter une couche au dessus avec
l'union européenne
moi je pense pas que ce soit vraiment
résolution et et je je je me dis qu'il
ya peut-être un autre agenda c'est à
dire que aujourd'hui les états qui
veulent s'endetter et pour soutenir leur
économie il peut le faire sans aucun
problème
d'autant que la bce vient à leur aide en
rachetant tous les bons des trésors que
ça me pour financer les déficits dont on
constate aujourd'hui il ya pas de hausse
du taux d'intérêt alors que les états
vont exposer leurs budgets et avec
énervante bons du trésor pour les
financer
donc pourquoi est ce qu'on veut faire un
plan au niveau européen moi je me dis
que la petite idée qui est poursuivi par
certains comme comme macron comme les
états du sud
ces deux dates d'années il perde était
une dette fédérale européenne
c'est-à-dire pour faire avancer la
construction européenne voilà et c'est
peut-être ça le vrai objectif servilité
de créer une dette européenne parce
qu'il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui l'union
européenne ne peut pas s'endetter elle
ne peut pas émettre de dette
elle doit avoir un budget absolument
équilibré ce sont les pays qui peuvent
être en équipe à l'union européenne
est ce que ça vous paraît viable ce
souhait parce qu'on sait que c'est
toujours compliqué entre les et les
états qui n'ont pas toujours la même
approche les choses une dette fédérale
comment se mettre d'accord là dessus on
se met d'accord justement ces cadenas
qui n'en veulent pas du tout et moi je
considère qu'ils ont plutôt raison les
pays-bas par les pays pays nordiques
parce que ils voient que ça va les
emmener dans un engrenage
ils vont devoir dépenser de l'argent
pour d'autres pays
donc sa saveur ça leur plaît pas aux
pays qui sont moins rigoureux que sur
les plans budgétaire donc ça ça leur
plaît pas du tout et on peut le
comprendre voilà en france on est signée
même pour la france ne sera pas un jeu
extrêmement gagnant parce que la france
va participer à ce plan
en levant de l'argent mais va en touche
et il nous sommes finalement assez
faibles on part d'une quarantaine de
milliards / / / et ses 150
donc si nous sommes plutôt assez faible
donc on ne peut donc c'est ça qui me
fait hier que vers le vrai objectif
c'est plutôt de de franchir un échelon
supplémentaire dans la construction
européenne en faisant une dette
européenne
alors la bce vous le disiez vous vous
suggérer un autre agenda que les états
puissent continuer à emprunter pour
soutenir leur économie il n'empêche
quand il ya une dégringolade
significatif du pib de la zone euro
attendue cette année 8,7 pour cent voilà
c'est le chiffre invoqué comment on peut
se relever de ce la 2d vous quand on
nous annonce ainsi compris en france que
là ce sera la pire crise depuis 1929 m'a
choisi pour choisir d'autres voient
qu'une loi exclusivement keynésienne est
basé sur la dépense publique il faut
aller lire des baisses d'impôts et dans
ce cadre là d'ailleurs l'annnonce de
bruit de l'eau mer aujourd'hui qui a
déclaré vouloir diminuer les impôts de
production que paient les entreprises de
type de 20 milliards c'est-à-dire 10
milliards sur sur deux ans ça ça va dans
le bon sens parce que ça ça profite à
toutes les entreprises
et ça rend la france plus compétitif par
rapport aux autres pays
et ça ça peut permettre vraiment de
limiter les délocalisations et d'inciter
les entreprises françaises à relocaliser
en france pour moi c'est plus dans cette
voie là qu'il faut aller c'est-à-dire
une baisse des impôts qui était seule
entreprise
et puis notre voie qu'on pourra
emprunter aussi cfc diminuer les normes
au moins de façon temporaire diminue les
normes qui pèsent sur les entreprises
notamment les normes environnementales
qui pèsent très lourdement sur les
constructeurs automobiles qui sont
obligés de faire des efforts énormes et
devant 2
à tout prix des voitures électriques
pour respecter les lois formés au niveau
européen et ça ça leur coûte énormément
d'argent et je crois qu'il faudrait au
moins au moins décalés dans le temps un
certain nombre de ces normes de façon à
permettre aux entreprises d'avoir de
pouvoir respirer un peu plus wallace
donc c'est dans ce sens là qu'il faut
aller pour moi baisse des impôts et
report ou diminution des normes qui pèse
sur l'entreprise web vous dites en
baisse des impôts mais voilà vous le
voyez au quotidien la dépense publique
est extrêmement élevé on sait que voilà
le mal français c'est d'aller toujours
sur la pression fiscale quand on a
besoin d'argent
cet argent justement où on va le trouver
pour compenser la baisse d'impôts que
vous proposez sellerie ce faire les
plans de relance coûte de l'argent les
baisses d'impôt coûte de l'argent aussi
donc on pourra dire où est ce qu'on va
trouver l'argent
moi je pense qu'il faut aussi se poser
la question de la dépense publique qui
est très élevé en france alors c'est
vrai que c'est plus délicat d'y toucher
en ce moment alors qu'on traverse une
récession mais il faut aussi se poser
ces questions mais il faut savoir que
soient les baises que les baisses
d'impôts ou les panneaux relance coûte
de l'argent de toute façon moi je
considère ce que ce qui est le plus
favorable pour la croissance
ce sont les baisses d'impôts donc il
faut mais un coup d'accélérateur là
dessus plutôt que de construire déjà des
échafaudages de dette au niveau européen
comme quand on veut le faire avec ses
750 milliards d'euros et le problème
c'est que ça va peser sur les
générations futures
et puis quelle assurance on va avoir que
ça vraiment que sa fabrique de la
relance économique
on sait bien que l'état n'ait jamais le
mieux placé perdre la croissance
économique à 1 donc c'est pour ça que je
suis très dubitatif là dessus sur toutes
ces dépenses publiques voilà donc la
france on espère un accord d'ici la fin
de l'été avec la collaboration de
l'allemagne vous y croyez vous à cet
accord
j'ai dit si l'avenir mais
je pense qu'on ne vont pas accepter et
ce plan et que il devra être soit revu
dans les tiroirs soit reconfigurer un
niveau plus modeste voilà si beaucoup
ont fini par en avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france